how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel where we talk
about all things relating to Marvel and
at the Marvel Cinematic Universe and
today we're going to be talking about
something that everybody has been
waiting for for a very long time the
x-men's introduction into the Marvel
Cinematic Universe now ever since Disney
acquired the rights back to the Fox
characters such as the x-men Fantastic
Four Deadpool and etc everybody has been
wondering exactly how long is it going
to take for the x-men to enter the MCU
and although we all thought that it
would be quite some time before we see
the x-men in the MCU because Marvel
would want to take their time and
introducing their characters and coming
up with their plan Kevin Feige name
dropped them at San Diego comic-con in
2019 implying that they are going to be
coming sooner than later now considering
the fact that Marvel hasn't really said
much about the x-men coming to the MCU
we actually know a lot about their plan
of what they want to do with them
including how they are going to
introduce them in fact it may surprise
you on just how similar their
introduction to the MCU could be to the
Avengers eventually going on to come
together form a team and have an x-men
film so in this video I'll talk about
everything we know so far about the
x-men coming to the MCU including how
they're going to be introduced which
x-men are expected to be introduced when
they're expected to enter the MCU and
some leaks and reports that we have so
far about the x-men joining some of our
current heroes and upcoming movies soon
if you're new be sure to subscribe to
stay up to date on all Marvel related
content and to enter my giveaway for a
chance to win an Xbox one or a ps4 more
giveaway details at the end of this
video so as I'm sure most people know
Disney and Marvel Studios since they are
owned by Disney have finally and
officially acquired the rights back to
the Fox owned Marvel characters these
include the entirety of the x-men the
Fantastic Four
Deadpool Galactus Doctor Doom and more
and so now the question is how is Marvel
going to introduce these characters that
have already been on the big screen
before under Fox
well for starters Marvel wants their
x-men in the MCU to be very different
than the Fox x-men and they're not going
to just come out and do an x-men film
like Fox did there has to be a
noticeable difference between the MCU
version of the x-men and the fox's
version of the x-men and some time has
to pass before a big x-men
film and this is so people don't confuse
the two franchises enough time has to
pass to where people don't think the MCU
version of the x-men is tying in to the
Fox version somehow and it's a lot
harder for the x-men because the
Fantastic Four are pretty easy it's one
team it's one film and a villain you
don't have literally hundreds of
characters that you could use so the
Fantastic Four is relatively easy to do
as long as enough time passes and the
last Fantastic Four film was some time
ago so enough time has probably went by
and not to mention the last film didn't
tie into the original two Fantastic Four
film so the continuity isn't really a
problem so based off of that and based
off of what Kevin Feige has said in some
interviews we know that Marvel is going
to introduce their MCU x-men in a few
different ways and the first way is one
at a time and this in itself could be in
several different ways they could do
solo films for new x-men coming to the
MCU or they could tie them into other
films with other heroes for example we
have two recent reports from mikey
sutton fellow marvel insider one of his
report says that rogue is going to be in
Captain Marvel 2 and that rogue is going
to be the main villain rogue is a
classic Captain Marvel villain and in
the film of course you would be a mutant
but the film is still going to be
Captain Marvel - it's not going to be an
x-men film or a film about mutants
whatsoever but they're going to throw a
mutant in there to be the villain almost
like they're not really making that big
of a deal about it they're just going to
gradually introduce them and build them
up we then have another report from
Mikey Sutton that states that the
Illuminati is going to be introduced in
Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness now in the original Illuminati
team from the comics there are several
mutants a part of the team and not to
mention mr. fantastic of the Fantastic
Four
and one of the main leaders is Professor
Xavier now Professor Xavier is an x-men
that everybody knows signature
wheelchair signature bald head so you
could introduce Professor X into the MCU
at any point in time and people will go
that's Professor Xavier the x-men are
coming but again this is going to be
during Doctor Strange and the multiverse
of madness it's not going to be its own
x-men film so this is an approach that
Marvel is going to take to introduce
some of these x-men introduce them in
other films without making that big of a
deal about it another example is Black
Widow it's highly believed that we could
see the very first mutant in the M
as early on as they debut of Black Widow
there's a lot of evidence that suggests
that Ursa Major will be in the movie and
although they may not come out and state
that he is a mutant he definitely is
Oliver Richards aka the Dutch giant
posted on Instagram before editing his
post stating that he was going to be
playing are some major he then edited
his post to make it not so obvious but
again this is part of Marvel's plan and
not to mention Disney Plus Disney Plus
is an excellent platform that Marvel
could use to introduce many different
mutants to the MCU because all of the
Disney Plus shows are in the MCU and in
fact most of the characters that get
introduced in Disney Plus will most
likely be on the big screen during some
team-up films and another thing to note
about the introduction of the x-men is
something that Kevin Feige basically
confirmed himself in an interview and
that is we're not going to get the
typical well-known mutants in the MCU
yes we of course are going to get some
main ones like Professor Xavier but we
are going to see a bunch of other ones
that haven't really gotten screen time
in any of the films when speaking about
finally getting the rights to use the
x-men in the MCU and introducing them
Kevin Feige said in an interview it's
not just the marquee names you know
there are hundreds of names on those
documents on those agreements the fact
that Marvel is now as close as we may
ever be to having access to all of the
characters is something I've been
dreaming about for my almost 20 years at
Marvel it's very exciting so when the
mutants finally do get introduced we can
expect to see some that are very popular
in the comics but haven't really gotten
any screen time in the movies and of
course right now Kevin Feige is really
big on diversity in the MCU and of
course there are many diverse characters
to choose from in the comics but here's
why introducing them one at a time
either in solo films on Disney Plus or
in other MCU movies is a really good
thing and that is they're basically
copying the way that they introduced the
Avengers when the MCU started they
didn't just come out with an Avengers
film would it have been popular and
successful if they just did that of
course but would it have been as popular
and as successful no the reason why the
Avengers worked so well is because Kevin
Feige and Marvel Studios introduced the
individual Avengers one at a time in
their own solo films we got to know each
character before they were a team and
watch them
go on their own individual journeys and
become who they are and they're going to
do the exact same for the x-men
especially the ones that go on to become
true x-men for Charles Xavier we're
going to see who they were before and
eventually Charles Xavier will recruit
them and bring them to his school and
that's when we will have our x-men film
it'll be done just like how they did the
Avengers they'll introduce Iron Man
Captain America Thor the Hulk
Black Widow Hawkeye and then have them
all come together Nick Fury brought them
together in the film and it's most
likely that somebody like Charles Xavier
will bring the mutants together in the
x-men film so you'll have solo movies
for people like Wolverine storm Cyclops
and of course characters that we may not
really know about but then we'll see
them come together and the x-men film
that the MCU does will be huge and so
much more satisfying because we've
watched each individual character be
built up over time now as far as when
they are coming to the MCU it's not as
long as you may think again Kevin Feige
mentioned the mutants at San Diego
comic-con and he said that they have all
of phase 5 already planned out and he
was going to reveal phase 5 but he
thought that everything in phase 4 was
already enough to talk about but he made
it a specific point at the end of SDCC
to save mutants Fantastic Four and blade
he would not name drop these if they
were not coming soon now a couple of
months ago it was revealed that Patrick
Stewart who of course played Professor
Xavier the original Professor X met with
Kevin Feige about Professor X Patrick
Stewart revealed this in an interview
when he said I met with Kevin Feige a
couple of months ago and we had long
long conversations and there have been
moves and suggestions which include
Charles Xavier this is straight from
Patrick Stewart's mouth so it is 100%
confirmed that this happened and he said
that as far as Charles Xavier is
concerned Kevin Feige has made moves and
suggestions so that officially confirms
that plans for the x-men in the MCU are
already underway whether that's
introducing one of them or many of them
in the upcoming future we are going to
see them in the MCU soon and the film
that is most likely going to set them up
is the Eternals now the Eternals
themselves are almost an away mutants
the Eternals were created by the
Celestials and they are described as an
shoot of the evolutionary process that
created sentient life on earth in the
comics a million years ago from where we
stand today in the MCU the Celestials
went to earth and they did experiments
on the early humans the products of
these experiments were the Celestials
and their counterparts the deviants now
it's widely speculated that in the MCU
there could be another byproduct of the
celestial experiments and they could be
mutants the mutants and the MC use X
gene could come from experiments done
years and years and years before by the
Celestials it's also been rumored that
in the MC the Celestials are not allowed
to have kids well some of them most
likely did and the offsprings of those
kids and so on and so forth could be the
x-men so the mutants are most likely
going to arrive in the MCU as early on
as phase four maybe even as early on as
Marvel Studios as Black Widow with the
introduction of Ursa Major
so the x-men are coming soon they're
going to come one at a time and be built
up just like the original Avengers were
and then they're going to come together
for their own x-men film what do you
think about this plan would you like the
x-men to be introduced all at one time
in their very own film or would you like
them to be built up just like the
Avengers were let me know what you think
about this in the comments down below
and let me know which x-men you would
like to see enter the MCU first be sure
to give this video a like and subscribe
but notifications turned on to stay up
to date on all things relating to the
MCU and so you can enter my giveaway for
a chance to win a Xbox one or a ps4 and
picking a winner at five hundred and
fifty thousand subscribers as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof woof